das wäre sensationell geht es jetzt
endlich los zum ersten mal soll eine
raumkapsel mit besatzung für die nasa
von amerikanischem boden zur
internationalen raumstation iss
befördert werden ihnen us-unternehmen
spacex soll die mannschaft mit der kuh
dragon 2 ss fliegen und den neuesten
angaben zufolge gibt es intern sogar
schon einen starttermin für den ersten
bemannten testflug und zwar sehr bald
klicks um science-fiction gibt zeigt die
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's ich will
kommen erst anfang des jahres 2020 hatte
spacex einen geplanten abbruch im flug
durchgeführt und damit sehr erfolgreich
die notfallsysteme der crew dragon
-kapsel getestet dieser testflug mit
einer geplanten explosion verlief laut
spacex chef elon musk zitat wie im
bilderbuch dazu brachte eine falcon 9
rakete einen dreck im raumschiff auf
eine höhe von 40 kilometern
dann wurde ein notfallsignal im
bordcomputer eingespielt und damit auch
der befehl das system für die notfall
triebwerke zu aktivieren und die
haupttriebwerke abzuschalten
die treibstofftanks wurden unter druck
gesetzt die triebwerke gezündet und das
raumschiff sicherheitshalber von der
rakete weg gesteuert letztendlich
landete drängender neun minuten nach dem
start im atlantik vor der küste floridas
und zwar mit seinen vier fallschirm der
explosion zu testen sollte offenbaren ob
die kapsel im fall der fälle für die
besatzung sicher ist und ja die
raumkapsel habe eindeutig gezeigt dass
sie im zitat unwahrscheinlichen fall
eines notfalls während des fluges sicher
von der rakete getrennt und zur erde
zurückkehren könne so die nasa dieser
test war die voraussetzung dafür dass
basics astronautinnen und astronauten
zwei ss fliegen darf wir hatten
ausführlich praktik substanzen fiction
darüber berichtet heißt also der weg in
den weltraum ist frei und das obwohl der
erste flug der dragons es erst im märz
des vergangenen jahres 2019
stattgefunden hatte damals noch ohne
besatzung nun also geht es an den ersten
bemannten flug zur iss nach angaben des
journalisten eric berger könnte dieser
schon viel zeitnah stattfinden als viele
denken berger twittert dazu working date
for space ex d motors is may's evans
dragons in good shape bornstedt ist
fluid and mission may move into label
obwohl slater
die pending on the number of wales not
heard the related no fire edition
education demnach ist reagan in einem
guten zustand und intern wird der siebte
mai 2020 als starttermin angepeilt
dennoch könne sich das datum bergers
angaben zufolge aufgrund einiger
variablen auch noch verändern
so könnte sich der testflug verzögert
und erst im laufe des mai stattfinden
aber auch ein start im april ist demnach
denkbar zitat eine reihe von variablen
nicht bei der hardware könnte zu einer
verschiebung des starts nach vorne oder
eben nach hinten führen berger zufolge
steht auch die dauer der mission selbst
noch nicht fest möglicherweise geht es
um zwei wochen doch auch hier steht eine
finale entscheidung nach angaben des
journalisten der beim onlinemagazin us
techniker arbeitet noch aus woher berger
seine informationen hat dazu gibt es
keine informationen was allerdings schon
seit einiger zeit fest steht die beiden
nasa-astronauten bob behnken und doug
hurley werden an bord der crew denken
sein und mit dem raumschiff zur iss
fliegen die beiden männer sind erfahren
für beide ist es der dritte ausflug ins
all
dennoch handelt es sich bei der
bemannten space ex mission um eine
spannende premiere denn hier werden
astronauten der nasa zum ersten mal von
einem privaten anbieter zur iss gebracht
daran hat die nasa schon seit langer
zeit großes interesse
denn seit dem ende ihrer space shuttles
ist sie aus russland angewiesen um zur
iss zu gelangen
dazu nasa chef jim brittens sein mit
diesen kritischen test stehen wir kurz
davor selbst astronauten den
amerikanischen raumschiffe mit hilfe
amerikanischer raketen von
amerikanischem boden aus zu starten ist
wahrscheinlich hängt der starttermin
auch mit der aufenthaltsdauer der beiden
astronauten auf der iss zusammen nasa
chef sean brittens dann hat er es im
januar 2020 angedacht den aufenthalt der
beiden auf der raumstation zu verlängern
denn statt der derzeit sechs astronauten
astronauten sind ab april nur noch drei
vor ort eine wesentlich kleinere crew
also die die ganze arbeit möglicherweise
gar nicht stemmen kann denn neben
wissenschaftlichen experimenten stehen
auch einige weltraumspaziergänge an
auch für deutschland ist das nasa
projekt commercial crew programm
entscheiden dazu ein mitarbeiter der
europäischen weltraumorganisation esa
die idee schmidt in einem interview mit
der bild für uns ist das sehr wichtig
weil unsere
die esa astronauten entweder auf dem
boeing starliner oder dem space
extraction fliegen werden auch der
deutsche astronaut matthias maurer wird
eine von diesen beiden raketen nehmen
nach plänen der nasa und der
europäischen weltraumorganisation esa
soll auf die russische sojus-rakete dann
nur noch im notfall zurückgegriffen
werden wow da bricht tatsächlich ein
neues zeitalter an space extrakt der
explodiert beim stabilen mass ist
begeistert da geht es um den letzten
unbemannten test der gut denken also
anklicken anschauen und astra.com ist tv
abonnieren super kanal von tim unbedingt
abonnieren also hier klicken drücken
machen bis dann bleib dran